يتحدث بصراحة عن الجنس من حيث
صلته بهذا الوباء
الدكتورة تيريزا تام ، كبير مسؤولي الصحة العامة في كندا ،
لديه
هذه النصيحة لأولئك الذين يرغبون في
ممارسة الجنس مع شخص
خارج أسرتهم أو ارتداء فقاعتهم
قناعًا ،
نعم ارتداء قناع تخطي التقبيل
وتجنب بشكل عام الاتصال وجهاً لوجه
أو التقارب
جيدًا الذي يثير الكثير من الأسئلة ،
صحيح تام يقول أنه لا ينبغي للناس
ممارسة الجنس مع شخص مصاب ،
أعتقد أننا جميعًا نعلم أن الانضمام إلي
الآن للحديث عن هذا هو سير مادود
هي  هو المدير الأول
لمكتب برنامج مسببات الأمراض الخاصة على مستوى النظام
لصحة ومستشفيات مدينة نيويورك
وسارة ، أريد فقط هل توافق
على نصيحة الدكتور تام ، ما رأيك في ذلك ،
أوافق على أنك تعرف أي اتصال وثيق
مع شخص فعال
هي وسيلة لانتقال محتمل لـ
covet 19 ، لذا بصرف النظر عن النشاط
أو الفعل الذي تؤديه ،
فمن الواضح أنك تعرض نفسك
لخطر أكبر ومن ثم تعرف
وضع تدابير التخفيف  مثل
ارتداء قناع وعدم الانخراط في
مثل التقبيل الذي يمكن أن
يتبادله أه تعلم أن اللعاب وسيلة لمنع
انتقال أه وأتساءل
يا دكتور ماداد هل تعتقد أن
الناس سيتبعون هذا يعني
أنا أفكر فقط على سبيل المثال  منكم يعرف الشباب
الذين يتواعدون ويقولون حقًا
أنك تخبرنا أنه
إذا كان هناك مواعدة وأن هناك
اتصالًا جنسيًا يجب أن نرتدي قناعًا
وأنه لا ينبغي لنا تقبيلك ، فمن
الواضح أن هذا يتغير حقًا
أه العلاقات الحميمة كما
عرفناها صحيحة ، فأنت تعلم أنك تعلم أنها
تعود إلى الحد من المخاطر لذلك نعلم
أنك تعلم أنك عندما تنخرط في
هذه الأنواع من الأفعال ، فإنها تزيد
من خطر
تعرضك لـ coven 19. و  لذا فإن
أفضل طريقة
لتوفير التعليم هي إخبارهم
بما يمكنك فعله
لتقليل المخاطر التي تتعرض لها ، كما تعلم
بإخبارهم بالامتناع تمامًا عن هذه الأنواع
من الأنشطة التي سنقوم بها
فقط وسنكون لدينا أشخاصًا يقومون بذلك بشكل أساسي.
الآن خلف الكواليس إذا كنت
ستفعل ذلك بشكل غير آمن وهذا هو
السبب في أنه من المهم تقديم هذا النوع
من المعلومات
لأن أسلوب الغياب الوحيد
لم ينجح أبدًا ،
لقد رأينا هذا مع فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية الذي رأيناه مع أمراض أخرى تنتقل عن
طريق الاتصال الجنسي
لا  للقول إن covid19
ينتقل عن طريق الاتصال الجنسي ، فنحن ما زلنا
نحقق في وسائل انتقاله ،
لكننا نعلم أن تبادل اللعاب على سبيل المثال
ورأينا أيضًا
أنك تعرف أن كوفيد 19 لديك جزيئات في
السائل المنوي
والمهبل والبراز وبالتالي
تتلامس مع هؤلاء.  من
المحتمل أن تزيد من المخاطر الخاصة بك ،
ولذا فمن الجيد
اتباع إرشادات الصحة العامة هذه ،
والشيء الآخر الذي سأذكره بسرعة
هو أنك تعرف أن الناس يعتقدون أنك تعرف
ما إذا كنت قد اختبرت ما إذا كنت قد اختبرت
للتغطية 19 وأنا  لديك أجسام مضادة جيدًا ،
فأنا لست مضطرًا لارتداء قناع ،
وهذا ليس صحيحًا ،
فهو لا يمنحك شهادة
صحية نظيفة بهذا المعنى ولذا نريد
التأكد من أن الناس يفهمون أيضًا
أنه ربما حتى لو كنت  لدينا أجسام مضادة
للغطاء 19 ،
ما زلت بحاجة إلى ارتداء قناع إذا كنت
منخرطًا في هذه الأنواع من الأفعال
خارج جهات اتصالك المنزلية